[Music]
in this challenge you'll need to unlock
a briefcase by decoding a series of
ciphers
each time you crack a code you'll get
access to more information which you
will need to complete the challenge
in this challenge you'll need to think
cryptographically to crack the codes and
retrieve the messages
remember to look for patterns and common
letters as you make your code theories
so that you can decipher the text and
then solve the riddles
i'm just going to very quickly tell you
about two kinds of different encryption
which is a way that we term plain text
which you can read into ciphertext which
no one can interpret right
you actually will have to do several
different ones but the two basic ones i
want to talk to you about are first what
we call a substitution cipher
now a substitution cipher
can work very very simply if we take
every letter in the alphabet say for
example a b c all the way up
to z we can just substitute every single
one of these letters for a number or a
different symbol or a different kind of
letter so for example if we were to take
all of the letters a to z and offset
them by five the first letter would be
written as the sixth letter which would
be an f
and then the next letter along would
become a g and an h
all the way and then i guess the z would
be well you'd have to loop back around
because there is not a 31st letter i
guess this would become an e so you've
got the complete loop okay now as you
can see this is a very very simple code
to break we'll let you start off nice
and gently however even if you didn't
know that every single letter was in
order right it wouldn't be too difficult
to break this code because say for
example
i'll just use another color here say we
actually had them all jumbled up and
just said oh i don't know maybe we'll
make this u
l t i etc and then we end on some other
letter like say
what have i not used a g okay now you're
then saying oh they're all jumbled up
how am i going to work out there's so
many more combinations but
it still isn't that difficult because if
you think back to our original alphabet
a to z
some letters are used more frequently
than others some are very common can you
guys tell me what's a really common
letter e it's e is the most common which
is why if you open up a bag of scrabble
tiles or something like that you see
loads of e's not many z's not many cues
and so on so this idea of looking at a
message
we look at this garbled up message we're
like i wonder what this says we can go
and look for the frequency of different
letters we might work out okay it was
going to be an m wasn't it would have
been the next letter
so e wherever it's really e will turn
into m and we will notice oh m is
clearly the most common letter in this
encrypted text so we would say that's
probably going to be
e does that make sense and that process
is called frequency analysis
so this is just the first kind of basic
cipher that i wanted to explain to you
there's one more that i wanted to show
you that's just
phenomenally cool the mass of it is
really amazing we can't go into all the
maps but i'll show you the basic idea
see all of this what's the math
underneath it it's actually very simple
it's just addition isn't it right
if we represent these all numerically
you know one turns into six two turns
into seven i'm just adding on a number
every time and addition is so
straightforward that that's why it's
easy to crack this right
the other problem is uh this key in this
case it'd be five five is the key once
you know you offset by five you've
cracked the whole thing right that
number there
is what we call a secret key if you use
that to jumble up your message and i
find out about it it's over i can
completely work out your message you
have to keep that key private and secret
right
this other kind of encryption that i
want to talk to you about is called
public key encryption
public key
the idea is
this number over here that we use to
jumble up you can actually just keep it
in the public anyone can know about it
but you still can't actually read
anyone's messages here's the way it
works it's actually very clever even
though it's called public key encryption
it's actually more like public
lock encryption
imagine what you had was a bag full of
padlocks right and you can say okay
anyone who wants to send me a message
just take one of these padlocks out of
the bag they're just out in public just
you know take that padlock and slap it
onto a box i'm the only person who has
the key who can unlock that does that
make sense how i can keep that number
in the public everyone can know about it
but you still can't read my messages
because only i have the key
i remember the maths here was about
addition very simple
how could we have something that uses
maths that keeps a number in public
but then allows you to have the secret
that actually unlocks it well here's the
way it works we take a number like this
a large number that is left in public
anyone can see it and in fact every
website that you have to log into or you
buy things from that keeps things you
know encrypted will have a number like
this it's obviously much much longer
it's actually hundreds of digits but
this is just for illustration
the private key is one of the factors of
this number now i'm just going to go out
on a limb and guess that you probably
don't know what the factors of this
number are it's been chosen very
specifically
this number has exactly
two factors i mean apart from itself and
one they happen to be 23
and 89. now can anyone have a guess
these numbers here they haven't been
chosen at random
anyone have a think what kind of special
properties might they have are they
prime
they're prime well done gemma that's why
2047 doesn't have any other ways you can
factorize it because if these had more
factors then so would this number right
now can you imagine if you had a number
like this it's hundreds of digits long
and instead of adding this number on to
everything you actually multiply by this
you get a whole new number at the end
because you've multiplied by this
enormous number and you've got here in
secret one of these numbers
you can very easily
undo the encryption that you did using
your secret prime numbers but if someone
wanted to try and find your secret prime
number they'd have to go through this
hundreds of digits long number and just
keep trying different options the kind
of encryption that we have at the moment
with these hundreds of digits they call
like 128-bit encryption
256-bit encryption that talks about how
large this number is
with today's fastest computers it would
take longer than the age of the
observable universe just to
unfactorize this number and work out
what the keys are and by the way by the
time you work that out guess what
tomorrow they've got a new key so it
didn't matter that you actually cracked
it isn't that clever that prime numbers
are used to keep everything that we do
on the internet safe
but of course your task today is to undo
that you're going to meet ciphered text
and we want you to create the plain text
that you'll get out of it
now
like i said you'll have several codes to
crack you're going to be using that
machine over there which has codes
inside it once you do that
there are three numbers that you want to
find out a
b and c as you crack the codes you'll
find those numbers
and then you're going to bring those
to this
which
looks like an embarrassing meme but
actually
this is this final number here is going
to be a combination to unlock a
briefcase and whoever gets to that first
and unlocks it using a b and c to solve
the equations they're going to be the
winning team for this challenge
in this challenge you'll need to think
cryptographically to crack the codes and
retrieve the messages remember to look
for patterns and common letters as you
make your code theories until you
decipher the text and solve the riddles
oh microscope
18. yeah we were all looking at it we
didn't know she was like yes yeah
microscope and we're like what
cool
okay
[Music]
you